[Music]
these prophecies will seem
strange almost impossible yet they have
come from the most learned and
conservative minds in america
to the wisest and most careful men in
the greatest institutions of science and
learning i have gone
asked each in his turn to forecast for
me
what in his opinion will have been
wrought in his own
field of investigation before the dawn
of 2001
a century from now these opinions
i have carefully transcribed
500 million people there will probably
be
from 350 million to 500 million people
in america
and its possessions by the lapse of
another century
nicaragua will ask for admission to the
union after the completion of the great
canal
mexico will be next europe seeking more
territory to the south
will cause many of the south and central
american republics
to be voted into the union by their own
people
the american will be taller by from one
to two inches
his increase of stature will result from
better health
due to vast reforms in medicine
sanitation
food and athletics he will live 50 years
instead of 35 as at present four he will
reside
in the suburbs the city house will
practically be no more
building in blocks will be illegal the
trip from suburban home to office
will require a few minutes only a penny
will pay the fare
there will be no c x or q
in our everyday alphabet they will have
been abandoned
because they are unnecessary spelling by
sound will have been adopted
first by the newspapers english will be
a language of condensed words
expressing condensed ideas and will be
more extensively spoken
than any other russian will rank second
[Music]
hot and cold air from spigots hot or
cold air will be turned on from
spigots to regulate the temperature of a
house as we now turn on hot or cold
water
from spigots to regulate the temperature
of the bath
central plants will supply this cool air
and heat to city houses
in the same way as now our gas or
electricity is furnished
rising early to build the furnace fire
will be a task
of the olden times homes will have no
chimneys
because no smoke will be created within
the walls
insect screens will be unnecessary
mosquitoes
house flies and roaches will have been
practically exterminated
boards of health will have destroyed all
mosquito horns and breeding grounds
drained all stagnant pools filled in all
swamp lands
and chemically treated all still water
streams
the extermination of the horse and its
stable will reduce
the housefly
[Music]
ready cooked meals will be bought from
establishments
similar to our bakeries of today they
will purchase materials in
tremendous wholesale quantities and sell
the cooked food
at a price much lower than the cost of
individual cooking
food will be served hot or cold to
private houses
in pneumatic tubes or automobile wagons
the meal being over the dishes used will
be packed and returned to the cooking
establishment where they will be washed
such wholesale cookery will be done in
electric laboratories rather than in
kitchens
these laboratories will be equipped with
electrical stoves
and all sorts of electric devices such
as coffee grinders
egg beaters stirrers shakers pears meat
choppers meat sauce potato mashers
lemon squeezers dishwashers dish dryers
and the like
having one zone cook and purchasing
one's own food
will be an extravagance
coal will not be used for heating or
cooking it will be scarce but
not entirely exhausted the earth's hard
coal
will last until the year 2050 or 2100
its soft coal mines until 2200 or
2300 meanwhile both kinds of coal
will become more and more expensive man
will have found
electricity manufactured by water power
to be much
cheaper
[Music]
there will be no street cars in our
large cities
all hurry traffic will be below or high
above ground when brought within city
limits
in most cities it will be confined to
broad subways
or tunnels well lighted and ventilated
or to hide trestles with moving sidewalk
stairways leading to the top
these underground or overhead streets
will
team with capacious automobile passenger
coaches
and freight wagons with cushioned wheels
subways or trestles will be reserved for
express trains
cities therefore will be free from all
noise
photographs will be telegraphed from any
distance
if there be a battle in china a hundred
years hence snapshots of its most
striking events
will be published in the newspapers an
hour later
even today photographs are being
telegraphed over short distances
photographs will reproduce all of
nature's colors
trains 150 miles an hour
trains will run 2 miles a minute
normally express trains 150 miles an
hour
to go from new york to san francisco
will take a day and a night by fast
express
there will be cigar-shaped electric
locomotives
hauling along trains of cars cars will
like houses be artificially cooled along
the railroads there will be no smoke
no cinders because coal will neither be
carried nor burned
there will be no stops for water
passengers will travel through hot or
dusty country regions
with windows down
[Music]
automobiles will be cheaper than horses
are today farmers will own automobile
hay wagons
automobile truck wagons plows harrows
and
hay rakes a one pound motor in one of
these vehicles will do the work of a
pair of horses or more
children will ride in automobile sleighs
in winter
automobiles will have been substituted
for every horse vehicle now known
there will be as already exist today
automobile hearses
automobile police patrols automobile
ambulances
automobile street sweepers the horse in
harness will be as scarce
if indeed not even scarcer than as the
yoked oxes
today everybody will walk 10 miles
gymnastics will begin in the nursery
where toys and games will be designed to
strengthen the muscles
exercise will be compulsory in schools
every school
college and community will have a
complete gymnasium
all cities will have public gymnasiums a
man or woman unable to walk 10 miles at
a stretch
will be regarded as a weakling
[Music]
to england in two days fast electric
ships
crossing the ocean at more than a mile a
minute will go from new york
to liverpool in two days the bodies of
these ships will be built
above the waves they will be supported
upon
runners somewhat like those of the
sleigh
these runners will be very buoyant upon
their undersides will be apertures
expelling jets of air
in this way a film of air will be kept
between them and the water's surface
ships with cabins artificially cooled
will be entirely fireproof
in storm they will dive below the water
and there await
fair weather
there will be air ships but they will
not successfully compete with surface
cars and water vessels for passenger or
freight traffic
they will be maintained as deadly war
vessels by all military nations
some will transport men and goods others
will be used by scientists
making observations at great heights
above the earth
aerial warships and forts on wheels
giant guns will shoot 25 miles or more
and will hurl anywhere within such a
radius shells exploding and destroying
whole cities
this video is sponsored by nordvpn a big
supporter of original content on youtube
so a lot of the videos on voices of the
past recently have been exploring
international perspectives and crossing
boundaries to understand how foreign
cultures
live and think and that is what a vpn
can do when it comes to netflix amazon
prime and many more
as you may not know i live in spain and
my version of netflix is focused a
little too much
on cowboy based soap operas so using
nordvpn
i've been able to enjoy american netflix
and glorious
american cowboy-based soap operas as
well as being able to protect your data
when using wi-fi in public places
and providing double data encryption
nord even works in china
very useful if you happen to have
traveled all the way to see kubla khan
and you want to document it on your
instagram stories for your squad back
home
try nord now and get 68 off at only 3.71
a month
and 89 for two years and get a free
month thrown in
by following this link or using the
coupon
thanks
[Music]
such guns will be aimed by aid of
compasses when used on land or sea
and telescopes when directed from great
heights
fleets of airships hiding themselves
with dense
smoky mists thrown off by themselves as
they move
will float over cities fortifications
camps or fleets
they will surprise foes below by hurling
upon them
deadly thunderbolts
[Music]
these aerial warships will necessitate
bomb
proof forts protected by great steel
plates over their tops
as well as at their sides huge forts on
wheels will dash across open spaces at
the speed of express trains of today
they will make what are now known as
cavalry charges
rifles will use silent cartridges
submarine boats submerged for days will
be capable of wiping a whole
navy off the face of the deep balloons
and flying machines will carry
telescopes
of 100 mile vision with camera
attachments
photographing an enemy within that
radius these photographs
as distinct and large as if taken from
across the street
will be lowered to the commanding
officer in charge of troops below
[Music]
there will be no wild animals except in
menageries
rats and mice will have been
exterminated the horse will have become
practically extinct a few of high breed
will be kept by the rich for racing
hunting and exercise the automobile will
have driven out the horse
cattle and sheep will have no horns they
will be unable to run
faster than the fat and hog of today a
century ago the wild hog could outrun a
horse
food animals will be bred to expend
practically all of their life energy in
producing meat
milk wool and other by-products
horns bones muscles and lungs will have
been neglected
man will see around the world
persons and things of all kinds will be
brought within focus of cameras
connected electrically with screens at
opposite ends of circuits
thousands of miles of the span american
audiences in their theaters
will view upon huge curtains before them
the coronations of
kings in europe or the progress of
battles
in the orient the instrument bringing
these distant scenes to the very doors
of people
will be connected with a giant telephone
apparatus
transmitting each incidental sound in
its appropriate place
thus the guns of a distant battle will
be heard to boom
when seen to blaze and thus the lips of
a remote actor or singer will be heard
to utter words
or music when seen to move
wireless telephone and telegraph
circuits will span the world
a husband in the middle of the atlantic
will be able to converse with his wife
sitting in her boudoir in chicago
we will be able to telephone to china
quite as readily as we now talk from new
york to brooklyn
by an automatic signal they will connect
with any circuit in their locality
without the intervention of a hello girl
grand opera will be telephoned to
private homes and will sound as
harmonious as though enjoyed from a
theater box
automatic instruments reproducing
original heirs exactly
will bring the best music to the
families of the untalented
great musicians gathered in one
enclosure in new york
will by manipulating electric keys
produce at the same time music from
instruments arranged in theaters or
halls
in san francisco or new orleans the
piano will be capable of changing its
tone from cheerful to sad
many devices will add to the emotional
effect of music
a university education will be free to
every man and woman
several great national universities will
have been established
children will study a simple english
grammar adapted to simplified english
and not copied after the latin time will
be saved by grouping like
studies poor students will be given free
board
free clothing and free books if
ambitious
and actually unable to meet their school
and college expenses
medical inspectors regularly visiting
the public schools
will furnish poor children with free
eyeglasses free dentistry
and free medical attention of every kind
the very poor will
when necessary get free rides to and
from school
and free lunches between sessions in
vacation time
poor children will be taken on trips to
various parts of the world
etiquette and housekeeping will be
important studies in the public schools
store purchases by tube pneumatic
tubes instead of store wagons will
deliver packages and bundles
these tubes will collect deliver and
transport mail
over certain distances perhaps for
hundreds of miles
they will at first connect with the
private houses of the wealthy
then with all homes great business
establishments will extend them to
stations
similar to our branch post offices of
today
vegetables grown by electricity winter
will be turned into summer
a night into day by the farmer in cold
weather
he will place heat conducting electric
wires
under the soil of his garden and thus
warm his growing plants
he will also grow large gardens under
glass oranges will grow in philadelphia
fast flying refrigerators on land and
sea
will bring delicious fruits from the
tropics and southern temperate zones
within a few days
the farmers of south america south
africa australia
and the south sea islands whose seasons
are directly opposite to ours
will thus supply us in winter with fresh
summer foods which cannot be grown here
strawberries as large as apples will be
eaten by our great great grandchildren
for their christmas dinners
100 years hence raspberries and
blackberries will be as large
one will suffice for the fruit course of
each person
plants will be made proof against
disease microbes just as readily as man
is today against
smallpox
few drugs will be swallowed or taken
into the stomach unless needed for the
direct treatment of that organ itself
drugs needed by the lungs for instance
will be applied directly to those
organs through the skin and flesh they
will be carried
with the electric current applied
without pain
to the outside skin of the body
microscopes
will lay bare the vital organs through
the living flesh of men and animals
the living body will to medical purposes
be transparent
not only will it be possible for a
physician to actually see
a living throbbing heart inside the
chest but he will be able to magnify
and photograph any part of it this
will be done with rays of invisible
light
[Music]